yy this is a case for against free zus
de against goodwill
that is, holidays from zus-u
yy prices or holidays
because vacation from zuzu is something like that
that for 3 months
that for half a year or a year it was not
The law in this
area of laws is ready and waiting for consideration
almost 3 years in the freezer
So we say there
in a difficult time
at the time when
You are not able to
pay with ears
mister mister no no then you have a voluntary zus
no you don't have to pay it
No,
Mr. Voluntary
people understand quite yy unequivocally
voluntary zus is then
when I as
Entrepreneur I can say no
We did not insure
We always explained it this way.
As it is in the law
You also have to save for retirement.
you have
not voluntary zus
This is a yy chance to survive movies in a difficult time
and this and this was
That was the difference between us.